foreign
[Music]
edition of the backstage podcast with
all the latest interviews and news from
the world of TV and film I'm Katie
Spencer and I'm joined here by Sky's
entertainment reporter Claire Gregory
hello and also coming all the way from
New York it's Stevie Wong TV and film
reviewer
hello coming up on this week's show
[Applause]
oh
a pipe squished me all out of shape
we got a dead body and a lot of people
to talk to what's your name hey Travis
first up it's a bit of a family-friendly
offering from Pixar and Disney which
poses the question what would happen if
Fire and Water fell in love this is
directed by the same director who did
the good dinosaur and Cars 2 uh Peter's
son and Claire you were fortunate enough
to uh catch up with some of the cast on
this what did you think for starters
yeah it's I think this is really cute
it's kind of a cute story it's set in
element City where all your elements
live together so earth wind water fire
and as you say fire and water two of
them they fall in love and it's kind of
about that relationship but it's also a
look at immigration and director
Peterson's been very open about the fact
that it's sort of based on his own
relationship with his American Wife he's
Korean
um and it wasn't just Peter who had a
personal connection to the story either
when I caught up with Leah Lewis who
voices our main character Ember and
Mamadou athi who voices Wade the watery
man
um he talks about how it had a really
personal connection for him as well in
terms of the story of immigration I
became a citizen while we're making this
movie um I remember even before like I
did Jurassic here I was almost not able
to do it because of the covert situation
shut down like the immigration offices
and bulbas I was like oh my God this is
crazy so doing this movie while becoming
a citizen while we're like you know
thinking about all the journey that my
family like took just to get here just
to well not here but in the states to
build a life it's been it's been
extremely moving and and
my parents they saw the movie of the
premiere
um and my dad had seen it like twice
since it's it's it means a lot to them
as well so it's so heartwarming to feel
that they care about it as just as
deeply as we do what did you think of
this Stevie do you think Pixar is really
doing enough to sort of change things up
I guess between each film I think
weirdly the the movie looks like a
sequel to inside out and I think
immediately people are like oh what's
going on and then when you watch it it
actually has nothing to do with it or
maybe this in the kind of weirdly
Universe of but you know this movie has
had the worst box office opening in 28
years of Pixar so uh this is not faring
well for for future films that that they
have in line I don't know I think I
think movies and you know animation
films or family films in general are
kind of suffering this summer problem is
isn't it the Disney are fighting against
themselves so they're putting these big
movies out in cinemas but families are
looking at it and going oh actually uh
we don't know if we're going to pay for
that when we can just wait a couple of
months and we know it'll come to Disney
plus so um it's a it's a tricky one and
I don't see a natural resolution anytime
soon well look if you fancy watching
Elemental it's out now in cinemas how
about though we move on to some TV and a
bit of a who done it's coming to Apple
TV plus the return of the after party if
you didn't catch the last series that
series season one all centered around a
high school this time the season uh
returns with a different murder mystery
based around a wedding we should say you
don't need to of course season one not
only do you to enjoy this no not at all
this is completely Standalone and what's
quite fun about the after party both
first series and now this is each
episode is told from a different
character's perspective and each of
those perspectives has its own genre of
the idea being that it sort of matches
up with that character's personality so
the Knight is retolding each episode and
you kind of get breadcrumbs along the
way as to the murder mystery so it's
it's a really kind of good fun way of
telling that story brilliant cast as
well isn't it Stevie that's one of the
elements that hooks you in with this oh
yeah not only is the original cast
members Tiffany haddish Sam Richardson
and Zoe Chow returning for the after
party uh this this season also has John
Cho Paul Walter Hauser kenjung and also
a certain Jack Whitehall
um we always have issues with this
accent and in this case uh apparently
it's it's still a problem is it just me
I still struggle to get my head around
Jack Whitehall being an actual actor and
not a comedian I mean it's a funny
character that he plays in this as well
and actually when when we spoke to him
for the podcast he said it's actually a
good one for him in terms of booking
future jobs he thinks it's also a great
job for your Show reel because there's
so many different little calling cards
that you can add into a Show reel having
done this and it's going to be great to
send it to our agent and say I want this
out to all of the directors in the
period drama space in the Heist movie
space yeah like this sort of shows that
I can do all of these genres to get this
to Wes Anderson let them know I'm a real
actor yeah yeah
well it might might not be sort of laugh
out loud hugely funny but it's
entertaining enough I think it's it's
what we agree on next up though a bit of
a genre mashing one for you a
coming-of-age story mixed in with a bit
of a gangster tale it's uh coming out on
sky and it's called then you run so this
is an eight-part drama based on a novel
called you
um and it follows four rebellious
teenagers from London they're sweary
it's um by A Series of Unfortunate
Events they end up in Rotterdam and
think it's it's a very bad summer
holidays they have on is this does that
sum it up correctly do we think yeah
they're trying to have the holiday of
their teenage dreams and it ends up
being something of a road trip as they
try to escape the danger they've got
themselves into it it really is quite a
dangerous situation but one of the
things I really love about this is these
teenagers are not written in a way that
is kind of very stereotyping cliche and
actually often we see teenagers on
screen they're not remotely realistic to
they're kind of what grown-ups think
teenagers are like whereas these guys
very much
um they seem very authentic and it's all
about the Chemistry Between the the lead
actors isn't it Stevie oh yeah totally
and what a good cast Leah McNamara who
you might remember was a normal people
uh Vivian Opera who was in rylane a
couple months ago and she was the lead
in that and she was so wonderful and so
nice to see her on this screen Yasmine
Monet prince who was in Hannah in the
show that we all liked and a newcomer
named is Adora fairhurst and so the the
fact that this these four uh young
ladies are so good together as friends
and they're very believable
um is is really the whole point uh of
this show and and it's just you know I
know you talked to them Claire recently
um about the series yeah when I caught
up with Leah and Yasmin I had to kind of
ask about this idea that you know quite
often teenagers they are sort of
overlooked or maybe underestimated when
it comes to their on-screen portrayals
as soon as I read the script it was so
natural and that's what drew me to it
just the banter between them especially
the fact that as girls they were just
cursing each other around you're like
yes this is normal this is what they do
especially when you're close to people
you don't really be sweet with one
another you just told them the truth for
you just kind of annoy them so I think
that's what really drew me too girls are
not like these perfectly Poise just like
I always looking lovely and like always
speaking so one and like like you know
braiding each other's hair and sitting
around and like having pillow fights and
just like girly things like I love how
they're almost like the antithesis of
that and but that is like Womanhood and
that's like you know being a teenager
and like being with your friends like
you're always slagging each other like
you're always having fun and I I also
kind of like I like how in my mind
they're kind of like the outcasts like
within their school but like they don't
want like but they're fine with that
like they are such a close-knit and I
feel like all their personalities are so
different that they all just bounce like
I think we all and we all bounce off
each other but the characters are all so
different and I feel like there's an
element in each person that someone's
like oh like oh I'm like Ruth like and
now way or like oh I have a friend
that's like you know so like saying
whatever it is so yeah I loved when I
read them it's a brilliant cast but also
just visually it's so well done and it
just has something there's something
about it that is just very edgy and cool
and different and I don't think it's
kind of weird original yeah original
yeah there's really nothing out there
right now that looks like this that
feels like this that has the kind of I
mean the the situations is pretty life
and death at this you know and yet it's
it's it's light-hearted and funny and
twisted at the same time and it's all
these wonderful things the thing about
this as well is when you start watching
it we've already said uh that it's got
the gangster element it's got the coming
of age thing it's also scandi Noir as
well because they're those first few
minutes of this it's uh of each episode
actually it's all in subtitles as well
which completely three years didn't it
Stevie because we were like you have to
watch this coming of age gangster thing
you're like wow what I think we are all
in agreement though that that is the one
to look at this week pick of the week
pick of the week very unusual and that's
out now on Skymax and you can also
stream it on now TV look if you have
enjoyed watching this the visual edition
of Backstage well don't forget we have
longer extended interviews on the
podcast itself with uh many of the stars
from The After Party Elemental and then
you run all you need to do is scan the
QR code which is on your screen now or
you can just look up Sky's backstage
wherever you usually get your podcast
from that's it for us for this week
thank you Claire thank you Stevie
thank you and we will see you again very
soon